first and foremost how's your comic-con
experience been so far what's it been
like huge is your first time ever what
surprised you most about comic-con
Thursday and you guys had Hall H Rock
and didn't you because then of you and
then this other guy Tom Cruise what was
that like did you cross pass backstage
or did you guys talk to him or anything
I tried to type it did you you tried to
take him down just because I didn't want
to share the limelight with anybody yeah
you were like dude don't don't get it
it's awesome
was it top gun on first or was it
Austria Lee was great down but it was
cool to see right I love we all stuck
around we had his top trailer was sick
yeah
first movie I ever did was with him and
I think he's a great guy um meanwhile
for the first time terminator gets an
r-rating what's how what's going down
that's gonna bring this our way in how
different is that how's that how are
things gonna be different is it the
first time isn't it first time since the
director the direction of our yeah so
pretty much the definition of pg-13 is
as I understood it when we began
we only get to say the f-word once so we
were all like arm wrestling over who
gets the moment that you know who gets
the moment where we had to use the
f-word and then by the end of week one
it's like yeah why'd you shoot I'm just
like this is never gonna work
and what's that line that you give
what's the line that you get or you use
that well there is that one let's hear
one have you got a lot of them go throw
it out there we're not machines you met
a mother oh I was going for the year
terminated oh well that was first yeah
yes you have to build on that this movie
is ten times that movie so we have to
say what's yours
oh you can't we all love the f-word
let's move on so you got to say it a
little bit of a lot it was funny you
came in here and you said you did not
feel like a badass until this movie why
is that well you don't necessarily buy
into everyone else's impression i or
label so I'm a hard worker and you know
I think I'm okay
in the second 104 attention but you know
like I've never gone around since that
moving on yeah I'm the badass
I'm the badass what the reaction has
always been that you're a bad like
people see you in their life
don't even say nothing I don't feel like
I really earned the title for myself and
until this film we're like I woke up one
day and I was like I'm getting through
this we are doing this I'm doing this 27
years later I'm a badass
it took time slow to catch up again
daddy
and you kept doing the stunt we were
talking last night she kept saying you
know we would do the stunt and I'm
having too much fun and I have so much
excitement written all over my face and
ten minutes every stops she was telling
me she's sliding down this thing she's
attached to wires just reaching over for
the weapon she's doing all these things
like she's doing a 27 years later and
it's 27 times more fun it really is I
want to know for the new folks what was
it like working with the og cast like
you know you grow up on these movies or
at least some of you grew up on these
movies not everything was important
right
I wasn't born Terminator 1 I was - you
were - so three of us here weren't a
half of us weren't even here so what was
it like now but I saw the movie I saw
Terminator 1 when I was like 9 and it
was my mom was like it's kind of violent
for nine years
it was not mentioned but I was so amazed
by this whole world yeah you see the
movies now on Deer Lake amazing the
effects and lean that Terminator 2 doing
his chin-ups and I was like I want to be
like her like she was amazing and she
became this icon that suddenly I'm
working with so it's it's surreal for me
it's it's just like she is an amazing
actress like I just love her on like on
screen her voice like everything she
does is amazing but also a great human
being so you know you got emotional
during the panel don't you talk it's not
a terminator
oh he's a public speedy thing you know
cuz we were at the wrap party he started
speaking to us and yeah just a little
too so we had two prophets going is he
gonna say that half worth five times
that was the over-under or online or and
he did it natalia did and I should have
just open that hit but I think cry a
little bit but I wasn't talking so I can
hide what you do cry do you guys did I
mean look everybody I'm sure get sucked
into it did you any Arnold
impersonations while you were on the set
or why you were hanging have is great we
had it we have actually I have the one
of you will put it on et so we all have
to we all had fun with the Arnold man
they're awesome these mash
they're really good really good I don't
wait a minute so you put it on and then
once you put it on like this tiny body
with this huge okay you've known Arnold
a long time did you go to the wedding
did anybody go to the wait did you guys
go to the wedding it was army chris
pratt's what no what a Helen a father
the Brian
okay let's remember father the bride
don't disrespect him like that
[Laughter]
how will they how will you win over this
new generation of fans because there are
the parents but there are the younger
kids who know all you all but their
folks like me who are coming because I
want to see Linda you know I think that
it's it's a combination of finding the
best ingredients of Terminator 1 and
Terminator 2 right you have the back
which is amazing
Arnold James Cameron a new filmmaker
with an incredible new spin on a story I
mean there's always so many stories that
can be told so many explosions you can
see what so what's that new twist
what's that angle that's gonna make this
action different or this sequence
different and that's where I think Tim
came in and really really killed it
you know yeah and being able to work
with this phenomenal cast and you having
three female leads yeah different have
you looked at these ladies I mean who is
going to bring in the newer generation
well having a left
[Music]
there everyone to come to see um of
course people generation want to come
see Arnold and Linda and see these
things and you know the younger
generation of course I'm sure that they
love Deadpool which is one of the best
high scoring r-rated films of all time
so they're gonna come see you got
McKenzie you gotta tell you guys well I
have that Deadpool fine you know there's
a little fun is like having an ear
infection from being in the tank for
three weeks and then hanging upside down
in a Hummer for three more weeks which
the minute that you reach the 90 degrees
because you have an ear infection
you also get nauseated so there were
several weeks raised like what would
look good on McKenzie if I threw it out
that was fun that was fun that was fun a
lot the ladies went through a lot
Kenzie's talk about your training and
how many hours you in the makeup every
single they should get back at 5:18 many
hours were you sleeping for it wait for
it was a it was a race to the finish
line I don't know what the expression is
it felt like we all just had to survive
it and then get through it and we were
all in the same sort of position where I
feel like we rotated days that we would
just like spontaneously cry it's not my
turn Peary
still dark and imagine the first table
reviewer Tim Miller yeah tattoos big guy
[Laughter]
great man but let me get back to your
original question yeah I was really
interesting when we started testing the
movie I was surprised did you expect
there is a lot of people who haven't
seen those movies yeah another story and
I was blown away and how well they
tracked the story even if they weren't
you know hardcore Terminator fans
because of the story we meant we tried
to do that but we didn't know we were
successful at that until you sort of ask
those questions the audience who aren't
hardcore fans right it will make sense
you won't so see you're like what the
hell whoa who was his uncle popped out
of nowhere right yeah we'll be happy
what what did it take to make you come
back um 27 years Oh 27 years I offered
him a lot of money it was 27 years and I
just thought well that is a whole world
a lifetime another lifetime to explore
um didn't want to just sort of repeat
the same endless loop mm-hmm but what
has 27 years done to this woman what has
time and what happe circumstance is done
and that gave me just an amazing
it ignited my imagination wedding what
has happened and who is she now and I
was intrigued by the brook will you guys
have a moment like she had with the
pull-ups you know I remember that in and
everybody remembers that the pull-ups in
every bozo there's a back is there
iconic physical moment because it's
pretty but everything she did was
amazing
I cannot wait she did Allen Hamilton she
just transformed herself with such utter
hey I know you want to say that war
again was just it felt very familiar and
she also made many more cultures that
kind of dedication she's in there for
3-4 hours doing her makeup in the
beginning so I come in late 7:30 a.m.
whatever and she's always watching these
art films so actually brought a lot of
culture to the trail I almost want to
cry to let you guys go
that on okay and if I cry you'll see I
swear I swear I will let you on the show
I will play back this clip of our bet
right there if I thought let's see you I
promise you
[Applause]
[Music]